the wait is over but only for some Italy
has allowed the humanitarian vessel
Humanity one to dock in its Sicilian
Port this after about a week of denied
requests there are nearly 180 migrants
on board but for now only Miners and
those with urgent medical needs are
allowed to disembark
Italy's new far-right government offered
a safe Port only after Germany and
France agreed to help and take in some
of the migrants
the ship will be allowed to remain in
Italian territorial Waters only for the
time necessary to allow us to see
onboard all the possible Health
Emergency of the people for whom I
promise Italy will take charge
earlier a tanker transporting nearly 16
migrants was also allowed to darken
Sicily before the group was processed
and transferred
but amid the hope for a new life in
Europe a tragic end for two people who
didn't survive
the nearby Waters others are still
waiting to dock hundreds of migrants on
other rescue ships like the geo-barons
are stranded in the Mediterranean Sea
some have been stuck for two weeks their
requests for a safe Port denied
conditions are getting worse for the
roughly 570 migrants on the ship
peoples they are fighting three to four
times in a day only because we are on
this boat and it's too difficult for us
to stay on this boat anymore
food and Medicine are running low it's
very easy for diseases to spread like
the ones we have respiratory mainly a
lot of coughing flu-like symptoms
on Friday Italy announced it would close
its ports to humanitarian rescue ships
despite tighter measures about 6 000
migrants managed to reach Italian Shores
over the last week
and more are waiting at sea
katsia Lopez Al Jazeera